[Aplausos]
i
y la verdad es que de aquí se ve
diferente y estaba acostumbrada verlo en
youtube esto mola buenas tardes a todos
quería empezar contando una experiencia
que vivía en el año 2007
que tuve la oportunidad de colaborar con
la fundación ayúdales a vivir
en la localidad de pachacútec en perú
muy cerca de la capital lima
se trataba de intentar
abastecer de agua potable a un pequeño
centro de información
y aunque la experiencia fue breve y no
llegó a buen puerto para mí fue muy
reveladora ver como una ciudad en
extensión similar a la que yo vivo a las
palmas no tenía en aquel momento ni
saneamiento ni agua potable para la
población se hacían cubas con el
consiguiente coste que eso tenía para la
población sobre todo en función de su
nivel de ingreso para mí fue revelador
y esque
no valoramos lo que tenemos yo no creo
que ninguno de los que estamos aquí hoy
cuando estamos en casa abrimos un grifo
y sale agua diga fiesta que vienen jaua
no lo creo
y es una pena porque
tenemos que darle a veces valor a esas
pequeñas cosas también sea mi madre que
me preocupara en disfrutar de las
pequeñas porque las grandes a veces no
llega eso es una máxima
la realidad es que a día de hoy en el
mundo una de cada tres personas no tiene
acceso al agua potable y dos de cada
cinco no pueden acceder una instalación
básica en la que lavarse las manos con
agua y jabón
nuestros hijos en europa soñaron con
eurodisney sin haber algún partido del
madrid del barcelona
algún incauto de la unión deportiva
pero la realidad es que en otras partes
del mundo
igual lo único que aspira es
a tener un baño caliente al final del
día
yo soy ingeniero
como sean en mi presentación me dedico
al noble oficio de extraer agua dulce
del agua de mar para que sea posible
usarla en otras cosas en nuestras casas
en agricultura en lo que sea
parece aburrido
suena a ello y de hecho cuando cuento
algo en casa del trabajo a mi hijo por
la cara que pone no me atrevería a
decirle lo contrario pero no lo es todo
lo contrario es apasionante poder
aplicar el ingenio a graduar a los demás
me gustaría reflexionar en esta charla
acerca del agua y en particular trabajar
sobre el concepto de como su adecuada
gestión
contribuye al desarrollo sostenible
el agua un recurso básico para el
desarrollo de la vida no solo para el
desarrollo de la vida también para la
dignidad de los seres humanos porque el
agua ayuda a reducir la pobreza ayuda a
evitar que proliferen enfermedades
además por su carácter transversal
el agua es materia prima de cualquier
actividad bien sea agrícola e industrial
el mundo está constituido en su mayor
parte por agua el cuerpo humano también
el cerebro en un 80 por ciento es agua
bueno en algún caso lo podemos discutir
yo creo que estamos
de hecho las primeras civilizaciones
fueron buscando el agua se sentaron en
las cuencas de los grandes ríos tigris y
el éufrates
ya no es que lo diga yo si quieren
hagámosle caso a un gran influencia del
siglo 20
a mi amigo bruce
el popularizó la expresión biwater
mainframe es evidente que se refería
otra cosa a la capacidad que teníamos
que tener de ser adaptativos a cualquier
circunstancia pero permítanme que hoy
aquí la use para que nos sirva de
vehículo conductor
hoy vivimos en una pandemia la del cobi
19 que nos ha enseñado lo importante que
es acceder a la higiene y al agua para
prevenir enfermedades una acción tan
sencilla como el lavado de mano ayuda a
salvar vidas
es fundamental por eso
las naciones unidas en su agenda 2030
para construir un mundo más equitativo y
sostenible
establece como una necesidad garantizar
la disponibilidad y gestión sostenible
del agua y del saneamiento para todas
las personas en esto nadie se puede
quedar atrás
y para contribuir a ese objetivo la
gestión integral la gestión del ciclo
integral del agua es sin duda una piedra
angular
introduzco el ciclo el concepto del
ciclo integral del agua porque hay veces
que hay que conocer lo que cuestan las
cosas para poder valorarla saber lo que
hay en el backstage para apreciar lo que
tenemos entonces
vamos a hacer caso al amigo bruce y por
un momento vamos a convertirnos en agua
y pensemos cuál sería el camino que
recorremos desde que somos captados en
una fuente natural o producido
industrialmente en una planta de
tratamiento hasta que somos conducidos y
llegamos aquí a grifo de nuestra casa y
qué pasa desde que allí salimos por una
red de evacuación y llegamos a una
depuradora donde nos acondicionarían
para devolvernos a la naturaleza bien
como un vertido al mar o bien tanto en
una segunda vida como agua regenerada
eso es el ciclo integral del agua pero
no ocurre de forma natural para llevarlo
a cabo hay que invertir en recursos en
energía así por ejemplo en canarias por
cada litro de agua que tenemos en
nuestros hogares emitimos a la atmósfera
aproximadamente 2,3 gramos de dióxido de
carbono
ustedes me dirán son solo 2,3 gramos
tampoco hay que pasarse claro hablamos
de un litro de agua
pensemos que a día de hoy en el mundo se
desala más de 90 hectómetros cúbicos al
día
eso genera además cifra que está en
continuo aumento eso genera una huella
del carbono
equivalente a la de 130 millones de
vehículos diarios
traducido para los que son de fuera al
idioma local años bien de carbonilla
[Música]
entonces vemos que el objetivo de
garantizar agua en cantidad y calidad a
todo el mundo entra en conflicto con
otros objetivos que son igualmente
importantes en la agenda de
sostenibilidad como son el objetivo 12
de intentar tener un consumo responsable
aunque tengamos agua no podemos
malgastar la el objetivo 13 evitar el
cambio climático hemos dicho que el
ciclo integral del agua y genera
emisiones de dióxido de carbono en
contra del cambio climático el objetivo
de 14 cuidar de los océanos está claro
que la actividad del agua genera
residuos que acaban en el mar bien como
vertido depuradora de desaladoras que si
no están tratados convenientemente
generan daño irreversible en flora y
fauna
la pregunta que cabe hacerse es cómo
llegamos al equilibrio como buscamos que
no entren entre sí en conflicto
objetivos que son igualmente importantes
para ello
en primer lugar
apostemos por el ingenio
el ingenio es esa herramienta que todos
tenemos en nuestro interior y con la
cual podemos resolver cualquier problema
al que nos enfrentemos
necesitamos innovar es fundamental
cambiar las cosas para mejorar
los actores del agua estamos obligados a
introducir con rapidez en nuestros
procesos productivos nuevas tecnologías
para mejorar y en este punto aquí y con
la mayor humildad permítanme que saque
pecho por el ingenio canario digamos
desde hace muchos años
administrando un recurso escaso y hemos
sido pioneros en aplicar tecnologías de
forma eficiente para resolver el
problema del abastecimiento a los
núcleos urbanos
aquí en el año 60 de la década de los 60
ya se deseaba agua hemos contribuido en
la operación para disminuir
drásticamente el consumo energético la
huella al carbono del proceso de
desalación hemos sido pioneros en darle
una segunda vida al agua para regar
cultivos campos de golf
hemos sido pioneros en mejorar el
impacto la dilución de los vertidos de
salmuera al mar
miren hoy estamos en maspalomas
si viéramos el principio turístico por
excelencia si viéramos una foto aérea de
donde nos encontramos de los años 60
aquí no había nada
y si no es por el agua seguiría sin
haberlo
tuvo un jefe que lo definía de una forma
muy gráfica que ahora no puedo
reproducir por la estética del evento
pero me venía a decir algo así como juan
carlos como falta el agua nos hoteles
nos cuelgan del palo de la mayor y tenía
razón
hubiéramos dado al traste con una
actividad que es el principal motor de
esta isla
además de el ingenio cómo llegamos a
aplicar el ingenio para eso hace falta
el elemento fundamental de la tabla
periódica es el ingrediente básico de
cualquier receta del éxito
no tranquilos hablado de prestar la
periódica que algunos hablador ha puesto
los pelos como escarpias no he dicho que
esto por lo menos aburrido no es y vamos
a ello se trata del elemento humano
necesitamos desarrollar talento
necesitamos formar tecnólogos en materia
del agua
y necesitamos motivar a nuestros equipos
de trabajo que sean conscientes no sólo
de lo que hacen de cómo lo tienen que
hacer fundamentalmente que sean
conscientes de por qué lo están haciendo
por buscar un mundo más sostenible
si conseguimos que trabajen con él
finalmente tendremos parte del éxito
garantizado
además tenemos que servir que esa
motivación sea extensiva a todos a los
usuarios que pensemos que cada litro de
agua que ponemos en juego es importante
y que estamos gastando recursos por
poner disponer de él
está claro que debemos de apostar por
modelos de gobernanza del agua en la que
administración
usuarios y actores empresas del agua
puedan participar en la toma de
decisiones por supuesto que sí pero
fundamentalmente en el que se sientan
obligados a comprometerse con la
sostenibilidad y eso es tarea de todos
antes lo ideal o denunciar estamos
acostumbrados a mirar para nuestro
círculo de preocupación esto es cuestión
del otro esto es cuestión de nuestros
políticos miremos a nuestro interior a
nuestro círculo de influencia si podemos
hacer cosas
ahora bien si queremos que las cosas
cambien empecemos por cambiarlas
nosotros mismos porque por sí mismas no
van a cambiar
resumiendo apostemos por innovación
apostemos por ingenio
apostemos por el desarrollo de talento y
por la concienciación social ese será el
camino del éxito y es que no hay nada
más hermoso que la evolución del agua en
su paso por la naturaleza
no hay
construcción arte humano que se le
acerque así que si amamos la belleza
preservemos también el valor del agua
me gustaría contarles un cuento espero
no pasarme de tiempo y que no se me
olvide porque si no esto sería viral y
la lió parda
cuenta la leyenda que un joven árabe que
vivían en un desierto muy cerca de un
oasis que le proveía de agua dulce el
joven quería compartir la riqueza con su
califa
y estaba dispuesto a cruzar el desierto
para llevarle una una tinaja de agua
antes de emprender el viaje su padre le
dijo llévate dos tinajas porque si no
morirás de ser por el camino y así lo
hizo cuando llegó a palacio el califa
agradecido por haber compartido la
riqueza con él le dijo vuelve a tu aldea
con todo el oro que seas capaz de cargar
y el joven ansioso en sacar a su familia
de la pobreza
cargo las dos tinajas de oro
ocurrió que no llego murió ese por el
camino
esto es una metáfora de lo que nos
ocurre a nosotros
estamos secados en el consumo y no
valoramos los recursos que tenemos no
los cuidamos adecuadamente
bueno yo estoy llegando al final no les
quiero hablar con tanta agua
empecé hablando de perú
y me gustaría acabar contando algo de
ese gran país latinoamericano en
particular
de una infraestructura que es un ejemplo
de ingenio las amor a las monas son
infraestructuras hídricas de la época
inca que lo que hacen es con una red de
kilómetros de canales sembrar agua
recoger agua del deshielo de la lluvia
para que sea sembrada y pasa el acuífero
y que desde el acuífero puedan ser
empleadas en épocas más secas en otras
zonas más bajas que tienen escases de
agua
no me digan que eso no es un
el auténtico ejemplo del ingenio humano
y de cómo administrar un recurso
nosotros lo tenemos mucho más fácil
nosotros tenemos la magia del agua está
en nuestras casas pero debemos de cuidar
de ella porque para poder disponer de
ella estamos invirtiendo en recursos que
son necesarios para todo el planeta y
hay que cuidarlo
así que si queremos garantizar el agua y
el saneamiento a todo el mundo a toda la
población
debemos de apostar por un modelo de
mejora continua que aúne innovación y
talento y que esté firmemente
comprometido con el medio ambiente y el
desarrollo sostenible
ese y no otro será el camino del éxito
si hoy cuando lleguen a casa
abran el grifo y encuentren agua
reflexionan brevemente sobre lo que les
acabo de contar esta charla habrá valido
la pena sobre aquellas pequeñas cosas
nada más muchas gracias
[Aplausos]